general Picton Pavel you are the chair
of the military committee and made of
the highest military authority at via
Alliance and I would like to ask you you
know how would you gauge NATO's combat
readiness in Europe well it's improving
increasing after two decades of
partnership no conflict no major crisis
with the exception of an are quite
distant crisis from European Afghanistan
Europe was living in a peaceful
environment unfortunately it has changed
significantly in 2014 and since the
wealth summit NATO is increasing the
readiness of the troops in all the
nations as well as the assets that are
owned by the Alliance and we believe
that it's an natural reaction to the
situation in Europe that developed after
annexation of Crimea and since so we are
aware of our primary task that is
protection of territory and population
of the allies we have to take the
measures that will be corresponding the
Security's in a situation would you say
that Russia is less afraid today than it
was two years ago I don't think so
it is how we perceive the threat threat
is always a combination of capability
and intent and if we are not so sure
about Russian intent
I believe that Russia doesn't have a
serious intent to attack NATO we have to
be realistic but there are significant
capabilities and military buildup and
modernization that needs us to be ready
for any opportunity and of course Russia
was using their military assets to
promote their national interests and
Russia frequently talks about the
protection of minorities wherever they
are and when we look to Baltic countries
so they have significant Russian
minority so naturally these countries
are concerned about the statements of
Russian leaders as well as by growing
Russian military capabilities and we
have to be ready for for for any any
even potential threat that's why we have
to consider Russia as a source of our
concerns British Foreign Minister Boris
Johnson said that NATO should consider
whether cyber warfare constitutes
grounds bridge rigor in article 5 how
would you react to that well this is not
a new argument we're discussing cyber
threat for long and summit in Warsaw
brought an agreement of heads of states
and governments that cyber was
recognized as another operational domain
and there are implications coming from
from America that recognition that means
that even our massive or focused cyber
attack now can be considered as a and as
an act of aggression that can trigger
article 5 response we have to be
realistic in terms of what are the
damaging effects of a cyber it's not
just disrupting the networks it's not to
create annoying effect cyberattack can
cause deaths as a conventional attack by
disrupting the networks of a traffic
control or disrupting of the networks
maintaining the systems into hospitals
or air traffic control it may cause
significant damage on lives so we have
to really take it seriously and that's
why that's why we take it as another
operational domain and we are taking
measures to be ready to address all the
challenges coming through cyber from
your perspective what would you say is
the biggest
challenge facing NATO going forward
internally it is a pace and speed and
depth of adaptation externally the most
urgent challenge to NATO is terrorism
and we have to deal with terrorism in a
more efficient way not only in this
physical element that means the
destruction of a fighting force of the
terrorist groups but also addressing
more the broader scope of terrorism the
feeding ground and the conditions from
which the tourism and extremism arises
and I believe that we have now adopted a
broad framework in Warsaw that is called
projecting stability initiative in which
we can address the needs of most
countries affected by terrorism in our
neighborhood and bring them assistance
that they need starting from this heart
fighting capability up to very soft
tools such as assistance in training
institution building equipment and
know-how and our intelligence sharing
and other areas that you can create grow
the framework for addressing terrorism
as a phenomenon thank you very much
general Pablo is great to have you here
you're welcome